لطالما كان البشر
أنه يحتل مكانة خاصة في
مركز الكون في العالم
جوهرة التطور ورفع
عيون الى السماء
ثم بدأ في استكشاف الرجل
اكتشف أنه يسكن كوكبًا
من بين أمور أخرى في النظام الشمسي
نقطة زرقاء صغيرة تدور حولها
من نجمه
كوكب بحجم عادي أخيرًا
بالأحرى يدور حول نجم
شاحب أن البشر لديهم أنفسهم
تصنف على أنها صفراء م مقاس واحد
سخيفة مقارنة بالكثير
عملاق وعملاق
خذ التكاري الكبير والرائع
مثال نجم مليون مرة
أكثر إشراقا من الشمس أو
uys kuti المهيب 5 مليارات مرة
أكثر إشراقا
الكون مليء بالنجوم الأكثر شهرة
أن الشمس تتألق عند القدم بشكل مجهول
التسلسلات الهرمية النجمية
لقياس المسافات الهائلة بين
هذه النجوم
حتى أنه اضطر إلى اختراع وحدة طول
خاص سافر لمدة عام
بواسطة جسيم من الضوء قال
سنة ضوئية واحدة وبالتالي كيلومتر واحد
كم هو حجم الكيلومتر
فيروس
والكون يقيس
80 مليار سنة ضوئية
[موسيقى]
النجوم مذهلة
كثير
مجرة واحدة تحتوي على ما بين 100 و
400 مليار نجم
والمجرات نفسها
لا تعد ولا تحصى
[موسيقى]
ما نراه حاليًا ليس كذلك
لا نجوم
والمجرات
[موسيقى]
للكون المرئي بأكمله
هذا يمثل ما مجموعه 400 سكستيليون
اللوحات القماشية مثل هذا العدد الكبير
أن الإنسان يكافح من أجل تصوره
ومع ذلك ، ليس الأمر بهذه الصعوبة
الكثير من اللوحات في الكون
يمكن ملاحظتها كقطرتين من الماء في
كل محيطات كوكب الأرض
أو حبات الرمل على كل هذه
شواطئها وصحاريها ولكن هذا
ضخامة نفسها تمثل فقط
الكون المرئي هذه المنطقة
بعد ذلك التلسكوبات
الإنسان لا يرى
جزء صغير جدا من الكون
حقيقي
[موسيقى]
يعيش الرجل في الضواحي البعيدة
من مجرة ​​غير ضارة فقدت في أ
الكون شاسع لدرجة أنه لا يستطيع حتى
لتصورها ككل مواجهة
هذه المقاييس الفلكية
لن يكون تافها
البشر يسكنون كوكبًا على صورتهم
مميز
واحد مثالي
الكوكب الوحيد الذي يؤوي الكائنات
الذين يعيشون على الأرض
هي واحة الحياة وسط الكبير
صحراء كونية هي حقا كذلك
استثنائي فالرجل واحد فقط
رؤية ضبابية للغاية للكون في
التي تتطور
على نطاقها هذه المنطقة كذلك
واسعة من الواضح أنه دعا لعدم وجود
أفضل
الفراغ
بعيدًا عن كونه أجواء تزخر هذه المساحة
للعديد من الكواكب أيضًا
متنوعة من متنوعة
نظرًا لوجود كوكب واحد في المتوسط ​​لكل واحد
هناك نجوم في الكون
ربما أكثر من 100 مليار
الكواكب
فقط في درب التبانة وبنفس القدر
في كل من مئات المليارات
المجرات الأخرى مع هذا
وفرة الكواكب كيف الحياة
ألا تستطيع أن تتطور بشكل فريد من نوعه باللون الأخضر
مرة
حتى مع احتمال المظهر
يبعث على السخرية ضعف أسراب الكون
ربما على قيد الحياة
خاصة وأن هذا الكون يتغير
باستمرار
كل يوم
275 مليون نجم حتى الكواكب
متنوعه
بقدر ما يحدث في نهاية الحياة
وكلها حركة مستمرة
الرجل لا يستطيع حتى التعرف عليه
الموقف الخاص الذي لم يتم إصلاحه عند
ابدأ بمدار الأرض
السباق حول شمسها هو
بسرعة 100 ألف كيلومتر في الساعة و
التي لا يدركها البشر
[موسيقى]
ليس أكثر مما يدركه فقط
النظام الشمسي بأكمله لدفع نفسه إليه
مجرته بشكل أسرع
[موسيقى]
ولإنهاء مجرته مثل الجميع
الآخرون هو نفسه فيه
تندفع إلى المجرة الأبعد
قرب أندروميدا بسرعة 720
ألف كيلومتر الرجل متفوق جدا
يبدو أنه ضاع في المحيط
الكونية في حركة دائمة
في هذا الكون من القياسات والمؤكد
أنه لا توجد حياة لا تعود
لغمس كوب في المحيط و
استنتج أنه ليس موطنًا للصيد
في النهاية البشر لا يملكون
أي فكرة عن مكانهم في
الكون
هل هم على الأرض أو مجرد تافهة
[موسيقى]
الأرض مهد البشرية
الرجل يسود هناك كسيد مطلق بدون
لا شيء يبدو قادرًا على ذلك
توقف عن ذلك
لكن كوكب الأرض لا يملك
انتظر الرجل لبدء عمله
قصة
[موسيقى]
منذ ظهور الحياة على الأرض
تستضيف أنواعًا لا حصر لها
نجحوا لأكثر أو أقل
منذ وقت طويل
لكن 99٪ 9 من الأنواع التي عاشت
الارض
ذهب بعض العار اليوم
تلوث نانت الآخرين تدريجياً
أنواع أخرى انقرضت
بوحشية
في المتوسط ​​مرورهم على الأرض
تدوم فقط بضعة ملايين من السنين
هذا هو تاريخ الأرض الذي كان يكتب
في كتاب من 1000 صفحة الحياة
سيظهر في حوالي الصفحة 185 7 حياة
سيمثلها فقط
خلية مفردة لأكثر من 700
صفحات حتى الانفجار النقدي
متعدد الخلايا
أنا أعيش من 170 إلى 880
ما كان يخرج من المياه
فقط في الصفحة 916
[موسيقى]
خلال هذا الثابت
التحول الذي أحدثه الكوكب أيضًا
عانى خمس نوبات كبيرة
قبل 250 مليون سنة
خلالها الحياة على الأرض
يختفي
أدى هذا الانقراض الجماعي إلى
اختفاء 70٪ من الأنواع
البرية و 96٪ من الأنواع البحرية
وضع الكوكب ما يقرب من عشرة ملايين
سنوات للتعافي والتعافي
رقصة التطور التي لا هوادة فيها
هذه الاختفاءات وجديده
الوافدين مثل هذا الوقت
الديناصورات في الصفحة 960 من التاريخ
في الارض
نعم
في نهاية الكتاب القصة كاملة
من الإنسان العاقل منذ ظهوره
حتى اليوم لن يكون الموضوع
فقط حفنة من السطر على طول الطريق
منذ وجوده في الصفحة الأخيرة
على الأرض وبالتالي تمثل 0.004٪ فقط
من تاريخها الطويل جدا
الرجل لم يكن موجودا منذ وقت طويل
ولكن ليس من أجل كل ذلك أكثر
تتطور جميع الأنواع في
ذروة التطور وكلها
مناسب تمامًا لهم
البيئة الطبيعية البرنقيل
الراسية بقوة على حوتها
وصولا إلى وقال ديك صغير و
تبدو هشة للغاية ولكنها باقية
لهجمات متكررة من نسور الثعبان
وليون استرخاء منذ ذلك الحين
لا
لا شيء يشير إلى أن الجنس البشري
يجب أن تكون أبدية ولا حتى أنها
يستغرق وقتا أطول من الآخرين
يختفي
الأكثر احتمالا هو أن مروره على
لا تمثل الأرض سوى نبضة من
رموش بمقياس قصتها
كوكب
مدة سخيفة
مشبوه
الإنسان نوع استثنائي
فريدة من نوعها في ذروة التطور
ولكن هل لديه أي فكرة عما
يمثل مكانه في الكل
شجرة الحياة
الرجل صنف نفسه بين
الثدييات من الثدييات مثل الخنزير الصغير
الأفيال زبابة أو حتى
الخفافيش والذهب
هناك أكثر من 5000 نوع من
الثدييات أكثر الأنواع بعشر مرات
من الفقاريات التي تشمل أيضًا
طيور الزواحف والبرمائيات
والأسماك
ثم يمثل الرجل واحدًا فقط
أنواع الفقاريات على ما يقرب من 70 بريدًا
ورقة واحدة في بئر كبير
شجرة
[موسيقى]
لكن الفقاريات ليست هي الأكثر
كثيرون على وجه الأرض بعيدون عن الإنسان
حددت بالفعل خمسة أضعاف النباتات
و 20 مرة من اللافقاريات
فقط لعائلة الخنفساء
أكثر من 300 ألف نوع معروف
[موسيقى]
تشير التقديرات إلى أنه سيكون هناك على الأرض بين
7 و 100 مليون نوع مختلف
[موسيقى]
لكن الأنواع الحية ليست كذلك
فقط الحيوانات والنباتات
الفطر
إذا أخذنا في الاعتبار أيضًا
فيروسات البكتيريا وجميع الآخرين
الكائنات وحيدة الخلية مكافئة
من أنواعهم يمكن أن تصل بعد ذلك
الألف مليار
ضرب بالآلاف من
عدد أشجار الحياة
إذا أخذنا نوعًا عشوائيًا
الأرض فرص السقوط على الوجود
بشري
سيكون صغيرا جدا
[موسيقى]
من أصولها وحيدة الخلية
تنوعت الحياة فيها
لا تصدق فروع النوع و
السيولة النقدية
الرجل الذي بدأ للتو
لمحة عن التنوع أو
والذي ربما لن يكون قادرًا أبدًا
مدرجة بالكامل
[موسيقى]
وفي هذه الغابة الشاسعة
تقع ورقة يعتقد بعضها البعض
مركزي بينما في كل الموضوعية
أقل ما يقال هو تافه
[موسيقى]
حتى لو كان مجرد نوع ضائع
وسط كثرة الأحياء
البشر هم بلا شك الأنواع
المهيمنة على سطح الكوكب
ولكن بأي معايير تتجلى
هذا التفوق
على الرغم من وجود أكثر من سبعة مليارات شخص
على الأرض الإنسان ليس الجنس
أكثر وفرة
أبعد ما يكون عن الرجال على سبيل المثال
أقل بثلاث مرات من الدجاج
حتى حساب الكتلة التراكمية ل
كل هؤلاء الأفراد الكتلة الحيوية
لا تزن الإنسانية أكثر من
النمل
[موسيقى]
ولا البشر
أطول
لا الأقوى ولا أولئك الذين يعيشون
لمدة اطول
[موسيقى]
إذا كانت بعض أسماك القرش أو السلاحف تعيش
المغناطيس أكثر من 200
يعيش المرجان والإسفنج
عدة آلاف من السنين
بل إن بعض أنواع قناديل البحر
قادرة على التجديد
أطلقت إلى ما لا نهاية دورة الحياة
بدون حوادث مفترسة يمكنها ذلك
ان نكون
وقاتلة
و
وإذا قارناها بأنواع أخرى
البشر ضعفاء
أمرا مقلقا
نجم البحر على سبيل المثال يمكن أن تفعله
دفع الجسم كله للخلف
من ذراع واحدة
[موسيقى]
كلمة أزمة والحصول على سنوات بدون
ترى شيئًا آخر غير القطرات النادرة
التي يجمعونها على جلده
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالوقت
النمر كان لديه هذا الوحش الصغير الساحر
يمر الانسان
لطبيعة صغيرة
مشكلته
شديدة السمية شديدة الملوحة
عند درجات حرارة تزيد عن 150 درجة
أو أقل من 170 درجة إلى
القضاء التام على الطعام
والأكسجين
ضغوط تزيد عن ألف مرة
لنا
للأشعة السينية والعالم
إلى فراغ الفضاء لا يفعله البشر
يدعم فقط مجموعة صغيرة من
درجة الحرارة
باو بخير جدا أجسادهم
معصوم من الخطأ وعلم وظائف الأعضاء الخاص بهم
قد يتساءل كيف هذا
الأنواع نجت حتى الآن
في ضوء هشاشته الشديدة
الهيمنة المفترضة للبشر
يبدو مثل هذا لا
بارز
أسرع وأعلى وأقوى
شعار الألعاب الأولمبية نحن
يذكرنا أن البشر هم
ولد منافس
[موسيقى]
هناك للتغلب عليها
وتفوق على الآخرين
ما عدا ذلك في الواقع
لا يتعدى كثير من الناس
ليس الفهد فقط هو الذي ينبض
بسهولة أعظم أبطال
عدو الخنزير الجمل وحتى
ذبابة بسيطة هناك
بهذا المعنى وقوي
قفزة عالية
بوما يحطم كل 100 رقم قياسي
المؤلفين حتى أكثر من 6 أمتار في
الأجواء
ووالده شيخ
خنفساء وحيد القرن لرفع الأثقال
يمكن أن تحمل 850 ضعف وزنها
ما يعادل رفع الإنسان 65
طن
بدون تدريب أختام الفيل
من نفس الشيء
تفعل كما يمكن للبشر الغوص
أعمق بعشر مرات من الأكبر
بطل حر
أكثر من 2000 متر
البقاء تحت الماء لمدة ساعتين
بدون تنفس
للرياضات القتالية لن يكون
ليس أفضل من البشر الأكثر قتالية
لن يحمل الراند مقابل أ
غوريلا دب أو كنغر
ناهيك عن العديد من الحيوانات
أصغر بكثير من يستطيع
الفوز بالقتال دون الحاجة
ليقاتل
[موسيقى]
مقارنة بالحيوانات الأخرى البشر
له أحاسيس أن أداءه لا يرى
ليس بعيد
في الليل
[موسيقى]
وهم أعمى الأشعة فوق البنفسجية و
الأشعة تحت الحمراء
والترشيح غير الحساس
[موسيقى]
لا يكتشف المجالات الكهربائية
ولا المجال المغناطيسي للأرض
أخيرا
قدراته الجسدية لتلك
من هذا الكوكب
لا توجد فئة 2 كثيرة
والأمل في
الألعاب الأولمبية الحية للرد
لأنواع أخرى
يظهر الإنسان
[موسيقى]
تافهة
قد لا يكون الرجل هو الأكثر
طويل ولا أقوى على وجه الأرض وهو كذلك
الوحيد الذي طور الذكاء
عقل استثنائي يسمح له
لتوقع لفهم لاختراع
عقل يمنحه التفوق
لا جدال فيه ولكن ما الذي يحدد
هل حقا
الناس
هل هي القدرة على الحل
قضايا معقدة
في هذه اللعبة تدير الغربان
جيد جدا
[موسيقى]
أو
ثم هناك استخدام الأدوات
ليس فقط القرود أو الطيور
استخدام الأخطبوط الذي ، بالإضافة إلى
دماغهم الرئيسي لديه
عقل مستقل في كل ذراع
قادرون على مآثر غير متوقعة
اللغة
[موسيقى]
خصوصية مين في الواقع
لا
معظم الحيوانات تتواصل
يمكن للنحل بطريقة معقدة
اشرح بالضبط أين تجد ماذا
أنواع الزهور أثناء الرقص
القردة العليا يفهمون اللغة
ويمكن حتى علامات
تنقل للآخرين ولديهم
أيضا مهارات الحساب الذهني
يضاهي الأطفال الصغار
حتى النباتات تتواصل مع بعضها البعض
هن
يمكن منع الأكاسيا
كيميائيا جيرانهم
عندما يؤكلون
تحذير السماح لهم بذلك
يفرز يتوقع السموم في
أوراق
ما تبقى للبشر
نظيف
الذاكرة طويلة المدى للوعي الذاتي
مصطلح
اللعب التعاطف والفكاهة
هذه المعايير الاستخباراتية كانت كلها
مرارا وتكرارا في
أنواع كثيرة
من الأكثر وضوحًا إلى أكثر الأشياء غير المتوقعة
حتى إبداع الإنسان يجب
المئات من
منذ آلاف السنين
ظهور النمل البشري
اخترع الزراعة بالفعل
الطبقات الاجتماعية تربية الحيوانات
عمل خط التجميع وشبكات
تواصل
[موسيقى]
إذا نظرنا عن كثب الرقم
الاختراعات البشرية ليست في الواقع
من نسخ باهتة من العالم الحي
تحيط به
و
أخيرًا عندما لا يتمكن حتى من ذلك
عدم تحديد ذكاء الأنواع
التي تحيط به تفوق
لن يكون الدماغ البشري
تافهة
كما يروض التكنولوجيا
المكاسب البشرية في الاستقلال و
التحرر من قبضة الطبيعة
[موسيقى]
ومع ذلك يمكن للإنسان أن يعيش
هي الأنواع الأخرى الماء الذي يشربه
يتم تنقية الهواء الذي يتنفسونه
جميع الأنواع الحية
التنوع البيولوجي
[موسيقى]
يوفرها هذا التنوع البيولوجي أيضًا
كل ما يأكلونه
ولكن أيضًا العديد من المواد
تشكل عالمه حيث المبادئ
أصول غالبية هذه الأدوية
[موسيقى]
لقد صنع الإنسان الزراعة
messan الملقحات
هذه الجهود الزراعية ستذهب سدى
يجب أن يقال أن النحلة يمكنها الزيارة
تافه ربع مليون
الزهور في رقم 16
وهناك 58 مليار نحل عسل
على الارض
[تصفيق]
الزراعة تستفيد أيضا من
اللافقاريات والكائنات الحية الدقيقة
التربة التي تضمن خصوبتها غرام واحد من
تحتوي الأرض على ما يقرب من مليار
بكتيريا
مقسمة إلى عشرة إلى مائة ألف نوع
مختلفة ، الغالبية العظمى منها
لا يزال غير معروف للبشر
[موسيقى]
إذا وضعنا ما عدا الحمض النووي لـ
كل هذه البكتيريا التي من شأنها أن تقودنا
إلى نهايات الكون
تنوع بيولوجي غني إلى ما لا نهاية
[موسيقى]
كل الأنواع تتطور في
التفاعل المستمر مع الآخرين
أنواع
الأنواع تختفي والروابط
المتبقي سوف يساهم في تعويض هذا
غياب آلاف الأنواع
تختفي في نفس الوقت والويب
من الاحياء كثيرا
ضعفت
خطر الانهيار بطبيعته
تبقى الإنسانية البيولوجية بالكامل
تعتمد على النسيج الحي للكوكب
لمن له حضوره
الانقراض كنوع
بارز
[موسيقى]
إذا كان الرجل لا يتميز به
الهيمنة لا بأدائه ولا
من خلال ذكائه لا يزال لديه
مع ذلك يقين لا جدال فيه
تلك الخاصة بهويتها غير القابلة للتغيير
ومخترق ولكن على مخاطر ذلك
لإثارة غضب الرجل يمثل بالأحرى أ
مجموعة من الأنواع المتعايشة في
الأكثر مثالية من التعاون
يعمل الإنسان بفضل العشرات
الآلاف من الكائنات المجهرية على و
في جسده والتي بدونها لا يستطيع
فقط لا تستطيع العيش
تنظيف سطح بشرته بالكامل
مغطاة بسجادة من الحيوانات
الفطريات المجهرية و
البكتيريا التي تعمل كدرع
يحمي من الالتهابات
ورائحة جسدها فردية جدًا
الشخصية ليست سوى تلك الخاصة به
خليط بكتيري معين في أ
خلاف ذلك عرق عديم الرائحة
في أعماق كيانه الخليط
من البكتيريا المعوية أيضا
خاصة بكل شخص لكنها ليست كذلك
لا يسمح فقط بهضمه
هم أيضا يؤثرون على صحته
أكثر على الصعيد العالمي
عقل ثان تقوم أيضًا بتشكيل هذه
سلوكياته المزاجية
وحتى سيكو وشخصيته
الكائنات الدقيقة في الجهاز الهضمي
هي عديدة للغاية مائة ألف
مليار ، عشرة أضعاف عدد
خلايا جسم الإنسان حتى لو
الخلايا الخاصة ليست كذلك
بحتة بشرية مما تعتقد
[موسيقى]
على تطور البكتيريا لديها
تم تدجينها وتجنيسها
حتى لا تغادر أخيرًا
العلاقة الحميمة بين الخلايا البشرية و
تصبح ضرورية لعملهم
وحتى على النطاق الأكثر حميمية
من الكروموسومات الخاصة به
استسلام سلامة هذه الإنسانية
في السؤال
منذ فجر الزمان
يتم دمجه بانتظام في جينومه
مئات من الشباب الاجانب
مجموعها أكثر من مائة ألف
شظايا الفيروس أي 10٪ من
الجينوم البشري بأكمله
[موسيقى]
أخيرا
الإنسانية في سلامتها ليست كذلك
لا شيء سوى ثمرة
مصالح التعاون السحيق spes
ومن هنا كل الادعاءات
الإنسان مقارنة بالأنواع الأخرى
يبدو أيضا غير مناسب
تافهة
الإنسان ليس مركز العالم
ضاع في أعماق الكون هم
مشاركة كوكب غير ضار مع
الملايين من الأنواع الأخرى كلها فريدة و
رائعة يعتمد عليها كليا
لرفاهيتها وبقائها
الغبار في هذه الضخامة الكائن
لا يبدو الإنسان استثنائيًا و
بالرغم
باتباع طريقه الخاص للإنسان
إتقان العناصر لصد هذه
قاتل المفترسون الجوع و
المرض من أجل البقاء ثم الازدهار و
قهر أخيرا
اخترع الفلسفة
علم الفن
[موسيقى]
ويطورها ويتغير الإيثار
توسيع نطاق وحجمها
الاتصالات من هذه التبادلات و
انعكاس
فرض على نفسه القيم و أ
الأخلاق والأخلاق
تدريجيا اخترع أيضا
السياسة التجارية الدينية
ولكن ايضا
التمييز
والتعذيب
وتطوير النزعة الاستهلاكية
ودمار الارض خير
استغلال الأنواع الأخرى في
نفس الوقت
حقق الرجل إنجاز الأحذية
أعلى القمم في العالم
وأعمق محيط في الداخل
أنواع
وخارج كوكب الأرض
[موسيقى]
كل دقيقة تلد 250
الأطفال وأنتجوا أربعة آلاف طن من
المخلفات
[موسيقى]
كل يوم وتنتج 240 الف
السيارات والليل
التالية
كل سنة
ترك ما يقرب من تسعة ملايين يموتون
الأطفال دون سن الخامسة و
دمرت 13 مليون هكتار من الغابات
يبدو أن الرجل يفضل الإيمان
لمعرفة رؤيتها
وصورة السعادة إلى أناشيد السعادة
يعتقد أنه أنا في كل شيء ولكنه لا يفعل ذلك
إنه لا يتقن الأنواع الوحيدة التي يمتلكها
طور قدرته على تدمير
البيئة الخاصة دون الحاجة
طور الحكمة لا
الإنسان المبكر جدا لا يزال غير ناضج
قادر على الأفضل والأسوأ
ينجح
منزله
[موسيقى]
هذا السؤال هو أي شيء إلا
تافهة
[موسيقى]